bienvenue au tribunal des variations
anachronique je suis miss minutes et mon
rôle est de vous informer avant que vous
ne soyez jugé pour tous vos crimes alors
installé tant coûté que je ne suis pas
nous vous conduiront devant un juge
jean-marie longtemps
mais qui peut croire à ces billevesées
critique et monsieur n'à
[Musique]
merci de votre visite dans les tpe
n'hésitez pas à le féliciter pour notre
équipe
qu'est ce que vous attendez de moi
vous avez altérer la réalité
je veux que vous nous aidiez à y revenir
pour quelle raison ça se passe très mal
deux filles à l'eau qui n'est pas une
excellente idée
j'aurai une arme c'est bon je sais vous
sans s'arrêter hors de question